was geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich hoffe natürlich
jedes gut wie man sehen kann oder auch
vielleicht nicht keine ahnung auf jeden
fall finde ich dass aufgestanden wir
haben samstag und heute habe ich
eigentlich überhaupt nicht geplant ist
dieses video zu drehen das ist super
nice und sehr spannend und ich glaube es
wird ganz interessant sich sogar
gereimter perfekt der ein oder andere
von euch hat eventuell ein video gesehen
wo ich diese bauern automaten abgecheckt
habe und wir haben hier noch eine
besonderheit ja so besonders ist jetzt
auch nicht aber ich wohne ja auf dem
dorf und wir haben hier zwei mal in der
woche so wochen mag und was noch dazu
kommt auf nahezu jedem parkplatz vor
einem supermarkt oder was auch immer
steht ein sondern hört einfach mal
vorsichtig sagen es ist eine mischung
aus marktständen und food trucks naja
scheißegal auf jeden fall habe ich so
viele davon noch nie probiert also die
stehen da schon seitdem ich denken kann
und ich war da noch nie deswegen hab ich
ihn heute gedacht wir checken einige
abgefangen uns erstmal zum wochenmarkt
da gucke ich mal was es da so gut als
frühstück und dann geht es weiter zu den
foo trucks ich bin echt mal gespannt was
heute passiert ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß wir fahren jetzt los das wir
gerne abo da und letzte so leute was
geht bin jetzt hier bei mir ne city ich
kenne jeden 2 das problem deswegen muss
ich immer ein bisschen aufpassen auf
jeden fall gehen wir erstmal zum markt
ich war so ewig nicht mehr war ich immer
so jeden samstag mit meinen eltern da
aber das ist auch schon zehn jahre her
noch länger immer gespannt ob es
überhaupt noch diese stände gibt von
früher zu wild frische feinkost
spezialitäten
dann gucken was ist auf jeden fall nicht
viel los was sie ist ein bisschen
was ist das hier
ach ja da nehme ich dabei man statt was
ist denn da neben dran
unsere schweine bedeutet auf jeden fall
[Musik]
leute das war wirklich eine super
lustige erfahrung
jetzt euch gleich mein auto meine
ausbeute ist auf jeden fall ein bisschen
mehr
leute brechende k gerade sind sehr viele
sachen hintereinander passiert
mitbekommen hat erstmal dieser brot
stand auf dem markt da waren nicht mehr
viel auswahl habt ihr ja glaub ich
gesehen und hab ich mir einmal hier
sollen körnchen die so ein schweinchen
geholt jetzt fand ich früher mal super
lecker und ja die sehen auch ein
bisschen anders aus als sie nach
bäckerei der das ist ja gemüse guten
habe ich noch nie gegessen vorher und
sie meinte ich muss den ball machen so
und hier haben wir dann das schweinchen
ja das recht auf jeden fall lecker dass
man ab heute sieht nicht schlecht aus
weiß ich kurz erzählen ich bin zum stand
gekommen und ich kannte also diesem
verkäuferin die kam mir noch so ein
bisschen bekannt folgen waren früher die
war ja auch schon ein bisschen älter so
oder ich riesig die sagen formel wir
eine frau und jetzt hat so lange
gedauert und dann kam ich an die reihe
dann habe ich den gemüse kuchen bestellt
und das schweinchen und das hat glaube
ich sechs euro gekostet da meinte sie
hast du zehn cent ich so nie aber sie
können sieben euro machen dann spuckte
und meinte ich ergeben sie mir drei
wieder sie guckt und gibt mit zwei
wieder ich dachte mir ja kommt abfahrern
nach hause passt schon man muss ja auch
irgendwie die lokalen marktstände hier
unterstützen gut wir hatten jetzt auch
schon ein bisschen später und der markt
macht sicherlich gleich zu trotzdem da
gab es eigentlich fast gar nichts außer
noch so ein paar brötchen schwein
zürchern und käsekuchen gemüse kuchen
und natürlich kann er auch mein papa
auch noch dazu der war damals gerade
durch zufall also dass es war wieder
klar jetzt hab ich was zu trinken
vergessen naja egal ich es jetzt erst
mal ein schwein solcher mir da sehen wir
uns gleich wieder so leute was geht
mittlerweile wieder zu hause und ich war
jetzt mal hier den gemüse kuchen ich bin
echt mal gespannt ich habe so etwas noch
nie gegessen in den ofen also ich weiß
nicht so ganz was ich davon halten soll
so riecht eigentlich ganz gut die nette
dame hatte mir ja empfohlen das ganze
heiß zu machen und das habe ich jetzt
getan bin ich mal gespannt auf ihr
gemüse kuchen ersten jetzt halt auch
einfach wie ein stück kuchen ist ja klar
das erinnert mich ein bisschen an so ein
auflauf denn meine mama immer macht
halt ich bin auf jeden fall sagen hier
ist drin blumenkohl brokkoli ein
bisschen käse was das dazwischen ist
weiß nicht genau paar worten das war
hart und sonst ist das wahrscheinlich so
ähnlich wie bei einem normalen buchen
aber ich mache das hier probieren wir
einmal hier
[Musik]
schmeckt ein bisschen wie brot workout
ja ich hätte nicht gedacht dass mir
schmeckt aber kann man durchaus als der
match auch fast schon mittags und ich
weiß vielleicht mal zusammen stand der
ist auch ein buch gepackt hat ich glaube
das ist eine berger gute leute dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder solche
nächster spot wir sind jetzt hier auf
einem autoparkplatz ich hab mir auch
gerade mal gepackt heimtextilien
bodenbeläge
die brauchen wir nicht ich war hier
eigentlich jeden morgen verarbeitet
waren lang und da ist vom burger standen
ja ich hab da noch nie gegessen wirklich
weil ich dachte man so ja als wenn das
schmeckt und wir müssen es heute einfach
mal testen deswegen ja das ist ein
bisschen schwierig zeigt euch das mal
hier mit der tür integriert hat nach
oben auf weiß nicht ob das klappt der
nachteil eines g8 zweite macht ist bei
uns jetzt ganz vorsichtig mal raus nicht
klappt ok glücker und abzubauen statt
ich hätte gerne einen cheeseburger und
pommes das wäre es glaube ich schon zum
wenn es geht zum mitnehmen habt ihr was
zu trinken hier amen achso 100 gramm
reicht nämlich menü halt einfach wort
christi
und cola ist auch bei
8 eur 60 danke britische firma bankrott
das ist so schade nur wirklich brauche
ich könnte so zeigen wie man leckere
burger zaubert damit jetzt zu hause die
pommes zu mieten oder auch auf die hand
leute ihr habt ihr gehört bezahlt habe
ich acht euro 60 dann kommen wir schon
auf den vollen worten es war schon ihr
habt den stand der gesehen ist es jetzt
ein fuß kann sicher schon aber halt so
ein ja also futacs sind für mich
irgendwie noch mal was anderes so da
muss das erst mal geil sein dann ist es
ein food truck okay ich habe ja noch gar
nicht probiert aber der damit fertig so
sind komplett gearbeitet das partie war
aus dem tiefkühlfach also ich glaube das
wird schwierig dass ich das überzeugt
aber will nicht zu sehr voreingenommen
sein vielleicht ist es ja in ordnung ich
probiere den bürger jetzt direkt leute
das ist mir wichtig weil jetzt ist er
halt noch frische so checkt das ab jetzt
richtig um zuerst eingepackt was ich gut
fand da sind zwiebeln gurken und tomaten
drauf dass er super super frisch aus ich
habe es euch nicht mitgefilmt weil will
diese leute irgendwie nicht einfach dann
stumpfe so sieht ganz so aus wir haben
diese bürger so drauf dann glaube ich
sogar rucola-salat diese bands die gibt
es ja ein supermarkt das sind nicht mehr
teure dann diesen sandwiches darauf ja
in ordnung kann man mal machen aber
dinger ich verstehe wenn man schon so
ein truck hat warum macht man das dann
nicht frisch so kein plan und hierfür
trotzdem 68 finde ich schon teuer also
für das menü mit der hommes darf so
leute ich bin gespannt
also das dingen trifft in soße schmeckt
so ich war letztens mal in münchen
darauf sein was war das auf dem
edeka-parkplatz wirklich schon burger
foodcheck der frische ware gemacht habe
die waren so unfassbar naiv schon mal er
hat hier seinen stand der ist ziemlich
klein aber da kann ich echt nicht so
ganz verstehen warum man das nicht
versucht richtig geil zu machen dass die
kunden auch wiederkommen weil du als
wenn ich so noch mal kommen hat ist halt
nix also schmeckt okay wenn man jetzt
mal hunger hat so aber nur drei von zehn
höchstens die kommen sind auf jeden fall
sehr gut gewürzt schmeckt lecker aber an
der burger 100 enttäuschen möchte ich
habe mich auch sehr gewundert wenn er
ist krass verbal wenn das an mir hier in
meiner eigenen city vorbei gegangen wäre
aber ich werde die leute wir finden
heute abend noch was geiles also das
kann ich mir gut vorstellen und dann
beenden wir das wieder hoffentlich mit
einem geilen essen
also mit mittag war es auf jeden fall
noch ein bisschen wärmer es werde licht
sagt ja wir haben mittlerweile abend
18.30 und jetzt geht es zum nächsten
food truck wie auch immer muss dazu
sagen ich habe jetzt noch drei im kopf
die ich kenne bei denen ich noch nie war
kein plan was es da gibt okay bei 1 weiß
ich aber da war ich noch nie und ich
glaube da werden wir nicht hinfahren es
sei dann die anderen beiden haben
zuweilen das kann sein ich habe keinen
plan wie langsam dinge auffahrt folgen
hier auf dem dorf weiß ich nicht wir
fahren hin leute let's go und erstmal
zudem erst den ich eigentlich am
coolsten findet zumindest vom look ja da
war ich halt auch noch die atsb so leute
angekommen er hat zu weiß aber gar nicht
was da steht fast schlee köstliche
bratwurst und ja ok schaschlik ich muss
leider sagen ich habe ein bisschen angst
jetzt alle zu haben dann wirklich 18 uhr
37 ja ja das war echt scheiße egal ich
kenne auch mehr weitergeht rückte dieter
okay leute guck mal hier war der hat
noch auf ist das grillstation gekümmert
da sind so ein paar herrschaften jetzt
muss ich erstmal hier im park vorzügen
okay also hier war ich zwar noch nie
aber die partner ist einfach gut aus
mein mikro ist gleich lernen wir vor
kurzem handy damit ich das ende gleich
jemand machen kann da ist richtig was
los sondern grillstation dass hier ein
gutes zeichen oder hoffe ich doch
ja
fast
egal was sagen dass junge der hat ja so
im drang zu lagern ich habe jetzt nicht
nur ein halbes hähnchen bestellt sondern
ich weiß auch noch wie ich meine papiere
beantrage hier also weiterhin stellt zu
mir nach hause gedüst weil keine ahnung
ich wusste nicht wo ich das essen soll
früher hatten wir öfter mal so hähnchen
aber ich würde niemals mehr auf die idee
kommen wir das zu holen das habe ich
echt ewig nicht gegessen bis hin zu
inhalt und hier haben wir jetzt noch die
pommes dazu wiederum ist das hat sich
heute mittag her erst naja
ebola das nächste und letzte food truck
essen oder wie auch immer man die stände
nennen also wie schon gesagt früher gab
es öfter mal bei uns von so einem jahr
wie hieß hat nochmal gibt es gar nicht
mehr hier auf jeden fall so ein imbiss
da gab es immer gute halbe hähnchen aber
da war auch immer brot dabei weil ich
habe das immer nur gestern mit brot habe
ich kein brot hätte ich mal fragen
sollen probieren wir mal die pommes dann
mal ein bisschen ein halbes hähnchen
hier
es ist kein lack an sowas auch wenn ich
eigentlich fast nie hähnchen essen
vielleicht ist hat nicht nur
das beste heute ihr könnt ja gerne
kommentieren gibt es bei euch in der
city auch so wahrscheinlich gibt es ja
überall nur bei uns hier sind wirklich
diese halbe hähnchen ständchen extrem
vertreten also die gibt es brauche ich
kenne hier bestimmt haben auf jeden fall
so um die 50.000 einwohner und hit save
so 67 von diesen hinten standen malakka
ist das auf jeden fall kauft wenn ich
wirklich sehr sehr gerne mal diesem
schaschlik stand probiert habt wenn ihr
sagt alex merkel unbedingt auch meinen
zweiten part mit den food truck food
trucks aus deiner city lassen gerne nach
oben da und schreibt auf jeden fall auch
weitere 24 stunden ideen kommentare was
soll ich mal einen tag lang testen ich
bin gespannt nächste woche kommen auf
jeden fall echt coole videos und für
mich geht es ja nach bulgarien dreht auf
jeden fall bild deswegen abonnieren
super gerne den kanal und wir sehen uns
nicht solche leute haut rein